est-ce que le fait d'avoir 12 enfants
fait partie de votre
bonheur pas tout à fait c'est un acte
d'avoir des enfants ce n'est pas le
bonheur est-ce que vous croyez que vous
avez eu malgré tout dans votre vie des
instants de
[Musique]
bonheur des instants de bonheur je
réfléchis hein je vous assure il
tellement je vois pas non
non avec mes ENF
oui qu'est-ce qui vous manque le plus au
fond ce qui m'a manqué c'est un
compagnon voilà un vrai compagnon je
suis vraiment seule avec mes enfants
toujours mes enfants lorsqu'on a neu
enfants on n'est pas seul quand même
non moi mon point de vue de femme je
vous dis je suis seule mon premier mari
était toujours malade il a vécu 7 ans
avec
moi il me donnait peut-être de la
tendresse mais je n'avais pas le temps
de m'occuper m'envoyer comme je je
voulais fallait que je travaille il
était malade fallait le soigner c'était
pendant la guerre en plus on avait du
mal à se procurer du
ravitaillement puis mon mari est mort et
j'ai reconnu cet homme qui était divorcé
lui ça a été l'échec
total vous aviez 18 ans ah je voyais pas
la vie comme ça voyaz ah je la voyais
comme dans un
rêve je la voyais je la voyais bellece
que vous y croyez au bonheur d'abord je
crois je crois qu'il doit exister mais
je crois que je suis en dehors moi ce
n'est pas pour moi qu'est-ce que c'est
le bonheur pour vous qu-ce que ce
surtout la la tranquillité d'esprit le
bonheur je l'ai jamais eu même étant
petite vous croyez que le bonheur c'est
une question de chance oui je crois
oui il y a un petit risque d'ici 3 ans 3
ans après votre mariage vous risquez d'y
avoir d'y avoir un malentendu je vois un
enfant qui qui sadera qui voyez-vous qui
qui arrangera les choses oui oui oui oui
que vous demande en général la femme qui
vient vous voir et bien mon dieu c'est
d'avoir un compagnon qui la comprenne
surtout qu' la comprenne ou elle veut se
sentir comprise et je crois que si elle
a si elle a trouvé ce compagnon pour
elle il y a une plénitude
certainement bien sûr l'argent
l'intérêt ça ça y
participe après bien sûr il y a
l'évasion il y a les voyages enfin euh
tout ça vous savez chacun ressent
intérieurement ses désirs et puis c'est
tellement
différent et bien vous voyez au fond la
recette est très simple l'évasion
l'argent l'amour et la société est bien
faite l'évasion elle vous la propose
payable à tempérament en 6 12 ou 18 mois
le bonheur est au
bout l'ennui c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
candidats aussi déterminé que vous à en
jouir aussi intéressé que vous à trouver
la solitude la détente le calme le repos
la paix le bonheur
quoi et ce bonheur payable à
tempérament ne peut pas être
parfait mais si mais si répond notre
société qui s'exprime souvent comme
chacun sait par la bouche de la
publicité l'essentiel est de consommer
et en s'adressant à vous madame elle
vous propose un roman du bonheur qui en
vaut bien un
autre un univers d'images multicolore de
parfum subtil de luxe discret dont vous
n'êtes pas exclu quoi que vous en
pensiez François Sagan et an Girardo ne
font jamais de roman photo bien sûr mais
lorsqu'on les met face à face avec la
notion du bonheur qu'en sort-il
je vais vous proposer un jeu là si vous
voulez bien il y a une actrice une
romancière je vous propose un thème qui
est le thème du bonheur bien sûr si vous
aviez à écrire et à
jouer le le le roman du bonheur comment
vous le construiriez ensemble qu'est-ce
que vous qu'est-ce que ça dirait
qu'est-ce que ça raconterait quelle
serait l'histoire je vous laisserai
d'abord faire ai bien vousz essayer là
bon B ben le bonheur c'est le bonheur
c'est forcément avec quelqu'un d'autre
donc ce serait le l'histoire d'une
rencontre je ne sais pas ce que c'est au
fond c'est c'est une impression je pense
qu'on peut ressentir une impression
qu'en montrant justement le malheur
quelque chose de très triste et alors
cette aspiration au bonheur alors il
devient concret alors ce moment dire ah
oui ah oui en effet ce serait bien la
pauvre elle est malheureuse mais elle va
avoir ça ça va être merveilleux je pense
qu'on ne peut l'exprimer que dans le que
dans le malheur
oui parce que le bonheur c'est rond
c'est comme un caillou ça n tombe sur la
tête et puis on est très heureux de ou 3
heur on peut pas pas faire une pièce sur
le bonheur parce que si on met en scène
un gros caillou on met en scène deux
personnages heureux c'est fini ils sont
là ils se tienent par la main il
regardent le public qui regarde avec
intérêt peut-être charmé mais au bout de
10 minutes quand même bien qu'il se
passe des choses qui entrave le bonheur
pour faire une pièce comm ça on
s'aperçoit qu'il avait le bonheur qu' l'
plus ou qu' va
revenir de rencontre de volonté quand
une femme dit je suis heureuse ça veut
dire par là qu'elle n'est pas
malheureuse c'est négatif elle dit mon
mari ne me bat pas mes enfants sont pas
malades je n'ai pas tell d'argent je
n'ai pas d'ennui et à de pas avoir
d'ennui je suis heureuse c'est ça me
paraî un peu un peu simple le bonheur ça
vous tbe dessus comme la foudre c'est
pas un paysage mais c'est pas un paysage
tranquille le bonheur nous sommes des
gens qui espèce heureus d'abord par
disposition et parce que on fait métier
qui nous plaît parce qu'on
gag parce qu'on gag notre vie comme ça
et parce que tout va bien une façon mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que le bonheur
me paraît une chose plus romanesque le
cœur qui bat la chamade on tombe dans le
bras de quelqu'un on est fou de bonheur
c'est ça et la mesure où c'est ça ça ne
dépend pas uniquement de moi ça dépend
si je suis plus ou moins amoureuse de
quelqu'un qui est là qui est pas là
alors le problème c'est justement vous
tomber en jade toutes les 5 minutes le
faire durer oui je d'accord voilà le
problème il y a une recette et non et
non DIRIS ma fille et non et non
qu'est-ce qu'il dit votre fils il dit
attends attends dit le fils de Françoise
Sagan mais attends quoi attant pour être
heureux c'est peut-être parce que les
enfants ne se préoccupent pas du bonheur
qu'en fait ils sont heureux car il est
étonnant de constater que les réponses
des gosses de 10 ans qu'on interroge sur
le bonheur commenc le plus souvent par
quand je serai grand écouez les extraits
d'une rédaction enfantine sur ce thème
Josian plus tard j'aimerais avoir encore
mes parents et les aider comme ils ont
fait pour moi Jacqueline avoir un mari
qui vive longtemps Patricia quand je
serai plus vieille je seraai heureuse de
me marier et d'avoir des
enfants Martine être heureuse dans la
vie c'est avoir des enfants petits
claire quand je serai plus vieille je
seraiis heureuse d'êt
institutrice Claudine devenir une très
grande danseuse classique Jacqueline le
bonheur pour moi c'est avoir un
appartement et être bien logé lid être
la propriétaire d'un beau cheval qui
gagnera des courses alors je seraiis
fier de lui
Nadine habiter à la campagne au grand
terre entouré de champ et de pré
cueillir les fraises des bois et sentir
l'arôme des violettes ou du muguet
Monique j'aimerais faire ce que je veux
être jamais contrarié par quelqu'un
Martine le bonheur c'est de se sentir
aimé par quelqu'un et de ne pas avoir de
remort Françoise mon bonheur c'est la
veille de Noël avec le sapin et les
guirlandes brillantes Béatrice être
heureuse c'est vivre longtemps et faire
quelques petits voyages Colette audri a
lu ses rédactions des enfants de 6e à
ses élèves de première et leur a demandé
de les discuter c'est un exercice qui en
vaut bien un
autre quelles sont les réponses qui vous
frappent comment les comprenez-vous en
général je trouve que ces réponses sont
des réponses d'enfant très m parce que
en dehors du de Noël du cheval et la
piscine le fait de trouver qu'il n a pas
de vra bonne
qu'il faut avoir un mari sa vie le même
je trouve que c'est des réponses très
mûes qui vraiment beaucoup de réflexion
pour des enfants si jeunes une petite
fille qui a dit qu'elle voulait vivre
absolument libre et sans contraintte moi
je trouve que c'est pas possible d'être
heureux elle sera jamais
heureuse c'est la seule qui envisage le
bonheur dans une espèce de liberté et
qui je dirais que c'est presque la seule
qui n'est pas raisonnable justement vous
êtes comme ça
vous il y en a d'entre qui ont des
frères est vous avez l'impression que ça
se pose que au fond ou que ils sont plus
facilement heureux que vous ou bien
qu'il se posent moins la question du
bonheur ils ont ils sont moins
insaciables de bonheur que la femme je
crois qu'à notre âge les garçons
trouvent estime déshonorante croire au
bonheur il se POS en dur
et il trouve que le bonheur c'est peu
s'attendrir sur eu même je crois je
crois que la femme cherche à atre ce
qu'elle veut ce qu'elle désire mais
est-ce qu'à votre âge vous dites les
femmes la femme la femme et cetera pour
vous actuellement à votre
âge c'est quoi le bonheur
[Musique]
euh comme je crois comme tout jeune fil
c'est évidemment de me marier mais quand
même d'avoir une carrière
et par la même de d'obtenir une certaine
liberté pour ne pas être sous la tutelle
même de mon mari et
[Musique]
oui j'aimerais bien s avir des enfants
former leur éducation mais ne pas être
je sais pas uniquement à la maison et
n'avoir que ce but là que de faire le
ménage et la
cuisine quand on est une jeune fille de
16 ans le bonheur c'est donc en
définitive une idée d'émancipation de
progrès mais lorsqu'on est adulte quatre
femmes vont se succéder dans ce fauteuil
très différentes les unes des autres
toutes nous ont dit qu'elles étaient
heureuses mais leur réponse indique qu'à
partir d'un certain moment on est
capable de faire la part des choses
voici la première madame de rider mariée
quatre enfants femme au foyer est-ce que
vous êtes
heureuse je suppose que dans la mesure
où j'ai des enfants qui sont en bonne
santé un mari qui est relativement
aimable et qui me me fait vivre
convenablement je j'ai tout pour l'être
mais en fait il me manque un tas de
chose comme tout le monde c'est ça n'est
pas une quoi par
exemple quoi du temps premièrement du
temps pour pour faire un certain nombre
de choses que j'aimerais faire
voyager je ne sais pas c'est c'est assez
hallucinant d'être mère de famille
d'avoir quatre enfants et de de les
faire partir tous les matins de
repréparer le déjeuner à midi de de
faire les lessiv de faire un tas de
choses comme ça ça ça se répète toute
l'année il y a pas de
vacances alors je souvent j'ai envie de
par exemple d'être seul je donnerai
n'importe quoi pour avoir 8 jours toute
seule je ne sais pas moi à la trappe ou
quelque part comme
ça c'est c'est peut-être pas le bonheur
si vous voulez ça serait au moins la
tranquillité vous croyez que le bonheur
égal tranquillité non non non mais pour
moi en ce moment oui je crois surtout
que le bonheur change de de visage au
cours des années si vous voulez vous
j'arrive jamais de rêver à une vie
idéale telle que vous auriez souhaité
l'avoir que vous souhaiteriez l' voir si
mais c'est très triste il arrive rien il
y a pas de souci il y a absolument
aucune raison de se bagarrer parce que
tout est parfait alors en somme je crois
que je préfère ma vie telle qu'elle est
maintenant que que cette vie idéale à
laquelle il m'arrive de rêver comme tout
le monde mais pourtant vous m'avez
dit il est probable
que je me suis marié à 18 ans il est
probable que à ce moment-là si j'avais
su j'aurais fait autre chose oui oui
c'est
vrai qu'est-ce que vous ariez fait
peut-être que j'aurais d'abord continué
mes études au lieu de les interrompre
parce que j'ai essayé de de les
reprendre il y a quelques années mais
c'est c'est trop compliqué j'ai trop de
de charges
familiale je pense que la plupart des
des femmes de mon âge maintenant
éprouvent le besoin de d'avoir une
activité autre que celle de la maison ça
n'est pas nécessairement le bonheur
d'ailleurs de travailler est-ce que vous
croyez que ça existe le bonheur
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je peux
pas vous dire est-ce que vous le croyez
vous voici madame Fèvre épouse d'un
ouvrier vous avez quel âge madame Fèvre
43 ans vous êtes marié oui vous avez des
enfants oui avez combien d'enfants
12 12
enfants qu'est-ce que c'est le bonheur
pour vous bien le bonheur pour pour moi
c'est une chose qu'on rencontre partout
à chaque pas à chaque minute de sa vie
allez vous promener vous voyez le
bonheur dans des feuill qui sort de
l'arbre dans le soleil est-ce que le
fait d'avoir 12 enfants fait partie de
votre
bonheur pas tout à
fait pas tout à fait c'est autre chose
c'est un acte d'avoir des enfants ce
n'est pas le bonheur il vous viennent
vous les prenez c'est tout qu'est-ce que
c'est votre recette du bonheur vous ben
c'est d'avoir comment je vous
dirais de suivre sa vie l'accepter comme
elle vous vient vous vient du malheur
vous l'acceptez de la joie vous
l'acceptez tout moment vous avez du
bonheur vous désirez quelque chose et
bien vous attendez qu'avoir de l'argent
pour chercher alors là c'est du
bonheur c'est à quel moment le bonheur
c'est quand vous attendez ou c'est quand
vous l'avez ben quand on l'attend quand
on
l'attend
arrivé
souvent encore
maintenant par exemple vous avezun plat
de pomme de terre à mettre sur la T y en
a beaucoup qui les BR au
ciel à votre famille qui est autour
aujourd'hui vous avez de pomme de terre
mais on est heureux que par le monde
beaucoup qui V bien être avec
nousen fait un peu de bonheur bon existe
pas peut-être choqué beaucoup de
personnes mais moi le bonheur complet
c'est
quand
euh vous arrivez au bout de votre roulau
alors vous avez fait votre vie droite
puis vous vous éteignez je crois que là
c'est le bonheur
complet quand il vous arrive de de de
rêver à la vie que vous auriez aimé
avoir
elle aurait été comment ah la vie que
j'aurais aimé avoir c'est pas avoir eu
tant d'enfants je les regrette pas loin
de là et puis de de vivre d'aller d'un
coin d'un autre discuter de
voir une vie pas terre à terre que je
m'ène voyez pouvoir
sortir vous avez l' d'être heureux mais
au fond vous l'êtes pas
tellement ça dépend comment vous
l'entendez à ce moment-l ça dépend je
suis heureuse de vivre déjà je suis
heureuse de conduire mes enfants
jusqu'au
bout puis après mais des fois dans la
vie je me révolte sur ce qui peut
arriver et puis après vous écrasez
je reprends mon fardeau moi oui oui
oui madame chaber marié TR enfants
infirmière à
Valencienne ce que vous pouvez peut-être
faire c'est de
définir votre bonheur si je peux dire il
a il a changé avec condition matériell
déjà parce que j'ai eu lorsque je me
suis mariée je me suis mariée très jeune
j'ai eu des débuts très difficiles au
point de vue financier avec mon mari
alors à ce moment-là le bonheur pour moi
c'était une machine à laver et cetera
alors qu'en fait lorsque je les ai eu je
me suis rendu compte que c'était pas du
tout ça le bonheur pour moi
personnellement je vous dirais que le
bonheur c'est le fait de pouvoir
communiquer avec quelqu'un le fait que
ça soit mon mari bon nous dirons que
c'est un hasard heureux enfin ça n'a
rien à voir le fait de communiquer
vraiment avec quelqu'un ça arrive en
fait très rarement je crois qu'on soit
marié ou pas on peut rarement
communiquer vraiment avec quelqu'un
pouvoir tout dire pouvoir dire ce que ce
qu'on pense on peut jamais être sûr mais
enfin je crois que mon mari et moi nous
arrivons à communiquer est-ce que vous
croyez que le couple est également
nécessaire pourevenir pour une
femme nécessaire c'est peut-être un
mot je crois qu' fond oui parce que il
doit être beaucoup plus difficile d'être
heureux tout seul que d'être heureux à
deux parce que les enfants font partie
également sont également nécessaires
pour la alors ça je crois que ça dépend
des
individus il y a des couples qui ont
besoin d'avoir des enfants il y d'autres
pour qui c'est c'est une gêne un
handicap énorme et l'enfant évidemment
parfois consolide le bonheur mais je
crois qu'en fait c'est un handicap tout
au moins tant qu'il est
jeune c'est un handicap dans la mesure
où il il handicape la liberté de la
femme si l'homme n'arrive pas à
comprendre que lui aussi est responsable
de son gosse et doit s'en
occuper l'enfant peut détruire ce que ce
que les gens appelaient un bonheur et
alors il y a une chose qui me frappe
aussi c'est en général une certaine
faculté de résignation chez les femmes
vous trouvez pas ça c'est la tradition
qui joue parce que de tout temps on a
appris au femme à se taire on leur
appris qu'elle devait s'occuper des
gosses s'occuper de la cuisine et
qu'elle devait servir l'homme c'est tout
cette tradition joue parce que même à
l'heure actuelle quantité de mère
apprenent ça à leurs
filles alors la tradition est quelque
chose d'énorme peut-être moins à Paris
quoi que ça joue encore mais en province
c'est c'est
catastrophique je crois qu'on serait
étonné de savoir le nombre de famillees
où on prépare la fille uniquement être
servante et son futur mari alors tout à
fait normal que la femme se résigne
parce que on lui a pris en fait on on
lui a pris à se préparer à se
résigner et dans ces dans ces conditions
est-ce que le mot bonheur veut dire
quelque
chose oui le jour où elle se rend
peut-être compte qu'au fond
elle n'a qu'une seule vie et qu'elle est
peut-être bête à la gâer à rester
derrière ses fourneau et cetera surtout
si elle peut faire autre
chose alors à ce moment-là je crois
qu'elle peut prendre son destin en main
et essayer de s'en sortir toute
seule CIS que ça lui coûte parce que ça
peut être au prix d'une séparation ou un
prix elle peut le payer très cher son
bonheur pourf ça doit être l'équilibre
le Bonard madame ré divorcé 2 ans enfant
enquêrice je suis restée une année en
chute libre c'estàd dans la solitude la
plus complète puis mes enfants étaient
très petits à ce moment-là et puis un
jour je les ai vu je les ai vu grandir
je les ai entendu parler j'ai compris
que j'étais nécessaire j'ai compris que
je pouvais me donner et à ce momentlà
c'était un éclatement un épanouissement
extraordinaire çaétait vraiment le
départ le début de de mon bonheur de ma
vie dans le
bonheur alors je crois que c'est
s'extériorisé le bonheur c'est c'est
quelques autres c'est quelques amis
fidèles parce que c'est vraiment dans
les coup d'Ur qu'on les retrouve c'est
pas quand ça va bien et le mot divorcer
ça fait ça fait frémir des gens bien
pensants vous savez ceuxlà sont partis
et puis les autres sont restés alors là
je les apprécie parce que ce sont les
vrais mais quand vous aviez 18 ans
quelle était votre vision du
bonheur justement c'est ça qui a étéit
terrible c'est que c'était je rêvais
d'un bonheur et que maintenant je vis un
bonheur et queil est différent de celui
que j'avais envisagé il est tout à fait
différent de celui dont j'avais rêvé
j'avais rêvé d'un compagnon dont je
pourrais partager les les
responsabilités les joies les soucis et
puis je me suis retrouvé toute seule et
j'ai pas pu les partager c'est c'était
tout à fait différent de du rêve à la
réalité je pensais pas que des enfants
seraiit mon bonheur je pensais que ce
serait un compagnon vous ne regrettez
pas cette vision du bonheur que vous
aviez à 18 ans
al ça aurait été peut-être
extraordinaire il y a peut-être je ne
connais pas de mes amis qui a vécu ce
bonheur d'ailleurs c'est ce qui me
console quand je vois non ça ça me
console énormément peut-être qu'il
n'existait pas c'était un
rêve alors on ne regrette pas un rêve on
préfère
[Musique]
vivre